Speaker 1: Major legal news Out of the state
of Georgia, a grand jury has been approved
to investigate Donald Trump's election interference.
Remember those 11000 votes he wanted?
Speaker 2: I need 11000 votes.
Give me a break.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: It turns out crimes may have been
committed there, and we may soon see the difference
in power between a congressional subpoena
and your regular good old fashioned district
court grand jury subpoena.
CNN Reporting Day four Atlanta area granted
special grand jury to probe Trump's election
interference.
This is not good news for the former president,
the article reads.
An Atlanta area district attorney investigating
former President Donald Trump's efforts to
overturn the 2020 results in Georgia will
be allowed to seat a special grand jury this
spring.
Fulton County D.A.
Fanny Willis requested last week to seat a
special grand jury starting May 2nd.
Some are saying that's an ambitious date,
but we'll see.
Fulton County Superior Court judges approved
the request on Monday, though the special
grand jury does not have the authority to
issue an indictment.
The move will allow Willis to seat a panel
exclusively focused on gathering evidence
in the Trump investigation.
She said she needed such a grand jury in order
to issue subpoenas to compel witnesses to
testify and gather evidence a step toward
pursuing possible criminal charges.
Understand this is all under the umbrella
of criminality.
Willis said she expects to decide whether
to bring charges against Trump in the first
half of 2022, which gives us that that debt
self-imposed deadline is June 30th.
Now can you do that between May 2nd and June
30th?
You can legal analyzes.
I've read say you can, but it is.
It is certainly aggressive.
Willis wrote last week that her office received
information indicating a reasonable probability
that the state of Georgia's administration
of elections in 2020, including the state's
election of president of the U.S., was subject
to possible criminal disruptions.
This is very, very real and very, very serious.
This is going to give the D.A.
Fanny Willis the power to file criminal subpoenas.
These are much more difficult to delay or
to avoid than the congressional subpoenas
that we've been seeing under the umbrella
of the Trump riot investigation.
As far as she believes, she has enough materials
to suggest crimes were committed and in theory,
at least depending on if and what Donald Trump
comes up with.
If the situation surfaces, she could compel
testimony to the grand jury to further the
belief that criminality took place.
Now, grand juries in Georgia have some interesting
rules.
The accused in Georgia does not have a right
to appear before a grand jury.
They don't have a right to have their attorney
appear before a grand jury.
They don't have the right to present witnesses
or cross-examine witnesses.
If you are accused in a grand jury is investigating
you in Georgia, you are not.
It is not a criminal trial with all of the
rights that come as a defendant in a criminal
trial.
You can testify or refuse to testify in accordance
with a Fifth Amendment invocation, and the
U.S. judicial system considers lying to a
grand jury.
Very, very serious.
And this is very quickly having the potential
to become a serious criminal matter
for Donald Trump.